je vais vous demander à tous et de
généticiens est-ce que vous pensez que
scientifiquement c'est possible de
réaliser ce que décrit monsieur orbite
dans son ouvrage est ce que c'est
possible aujourd'hui de le faire oui ou
non
en amalgamant trois techniques qui ne
l'ont jamais été dont certaines sont
très anciennes celles du bouturage que
mon ami jacquard rappelait tout à
l'heure à propos des grenouilles celle
de ce qu'on appelle l'utérus mercenaires
c'est à dire je lui explique rapidement
chez les moutons il ya des moutons
ordinaire il ya un mouton mérinos dont
la laine représente 10% du poids il est
théoriquement possible et ça a été
réalisée de faire commencer chez une
brebis de race une grossesse qui
théoriquement devrait durer cent
quarante cinq jours de la tromper de
réimplanter cette offre dans l'utérus
d'une brebis tout à fait quelconque ce
qui permet de gagner beaucoup du temps
et de remettre en route à nouveau des
moutons mérinos ça existe et puis le
troisième l'an technique
c'est le plan qui a peut être été
réalisée on ne sait pas très bien en
angleterre chez une femme qui avait eu
les troncs plier supprimer qui a désiré
avoir un enfant et qui a eu
l'intervention suivante prélèvement d'un
ovule par coelioscopie insémination
artificielle par le sperme du mari est
paraît-il réimplantation et succès on a
court circuité la trompe quand vous
amalgamez les trois techniques vous ne
pouvez plus parler de science fiction
c'est de la science mais je crois
anticipation est assez